yes but especially could I see it you me
and I'm gonna need one two brothers
after this okay let's just consider a
simple one first if you've got something
like say X plus a constant
okay and it's raised to some power and
okay let's just do a regular chain rule
the one that we're familiar with okay
the power comes out the front and then
it - one good leave reduces okay then
for if I'm going to reverse this process
okay the powers gonna power up right so
you can completely see how they reverse
each other so what I've got is chain
rule this way
yeah you mean you mean the primitive
original this one yes and if another
constant - that doesn't that mean the
next one has even more different yes
that's right so this is my starting
point right so undefined this is what I
could just buy any okay okay so I could
define this as anything I'm like this is
what I'm interested in because I have a
constant there yeah it's gonna it's
gonna become a constant times infinity
so this is not my styling okay okay so
if I go chain rule and up here
if I go reverse chain rule this is okay
yeah just to step it up a little bit if
what I've got in here okay has a
constant coefficient so something like
hey X plus B that's it again okay when I
differentiate but power comes out the
front but also the derivative of the
inside comes out the front so I'm going
to get a and you guys know this already
right and then the power drops down and
then if we go the other direction your
vessel okay so power goes then divided
by that derivative and the new power
okay now what'll happen is this table is
going to grow oh look a trig functions
we'll look at Exponential's we're
probably won't have time for logs but